[Music]
following total atomic annihilation the
rebuilding of this great nation of ours
may fall to you that's why we love tech
have prepared these educational
materials for you to better understand
the seven defining attributes that make
you special
and now charisma what is it made of
unlike the clean wholesome America you
may recall the wasteland will be a
distrustful place full of unsavory
characters and a few lorries earning the
trust of your fellow man is an often
overlooked key to survival one way to
prove your trustworthiness is through
fair commercial exchange your renowned
charisma will enable more favorable
bartering don't get greedy now use your
charismatic nature to negotiate your way
out of tense moments having friends is
always of value how else do I find
friends you may wonder you may find an
impromptu cocktail hour helps to ease
social stress your charisma will help
you avoid the perils of addiction but
not the immediate effects of drink so
practice moderation or you'll find out
who your real friends are
hardway you will find that even wild
animals can be charmed by your charisma
looks like you found a new pal oh-ho
don't get carried away there big fella
so you see taking the charismatic
approach is more than just good manners
working with man's best friend into more
loyal companions with fencing others to
act on your behalf
regularly study your vault-tec provided
materials to prepare for survival and to
answer the question do you know what
makes you special
[Music]